all right let's get into this week's
mailbag i got a weird email from someone
last week saying i should call this my
apple bag which is just strange i think
it relates to that weird nicki minaj
story and i talked about apple bags but
i don't think apple bags is an
appropriate name for this segment this
is the mailbag
you can participate maybe if your email
is interesting and smart enough or crazy
enough right there's two types
by emailing info davidpakman.com
this has been uh an increasingly popular
segment emails are just dumping in
people wanting their questions answered
uh let's just get right into it folks
please
starting with brian brian wrote i don't
even care that brian spelled my name
wrong he says mr pakman
i enjoy your show i have heard you
comment a few times about donald trump
misstating the 1918 spanish flu by
repeating 1917 spanish flu he is not
getting this wrong on accident seventeen
is a kewanon reference or canine as some
say or shout out every time he uses 17
incorrectly it is done purposefully
thank you for what you do yeah we had a
caller last week on live calls who said
the same thing which is q is the 17th
letter of the alphabet right i'm so m is
13
n
14
o 15
p 16 q 17 that that part checks out
maybe that's true i've now heard this
from a few people
maybe yeah i don't know and if that's
the case it would be
really
disturbing about what it says about
former president trump that he is sort
of surreptitiously signaling to the q a
non-conspiracy theorist i would put
nothing past trump whatsoever part of me
wonders whether he's clever or smart
enough to even do that maybe somebody
gave him the idea i think the most
likely explanation is also the simplest
one trump misstated the 1918 flu as the
1917 flu once
nobody corrected him
or they did but trump is too much of a
narcissist to change it because it would
concede that he said something wrong so
he's just continuing to call it the 1917
flu that that's my uh sort of guess next
email is from wayno wayno says sir
how does youtube's ban on misinformation
affect joe rogan
it's a good question i think you're
referring to youtube banning all
anti-vaxx stuff it's pretty clear to me
that joe rogan is staying
on this side of the youtube rules
um
some of his guests maybe on their own
channels are going past that line
but my instinct in looking at the
updated rules and remember that the
updated rules from youtube about they've
banned anti-vaxxers and anti-vaxx
content
um it
the it was already in place for covid
vaccine stuff they've just expanded it
to be all anti-vac stuff and so since
the controversial subject matter on
rogan's channel has been about when it
comes to vaccines the coveted vaccine
that ban was already in place so i don't
actually think that the new rules will
really affect rogan a lot of people may
not know this but there's much more
content demonetized on youtube
than there is removed there's actually i
mean of course like straight up gore and
violence and out and out
conspiracy anti-vax stuff it's removed
the vast majority of content is just
demonetized when it violates terms and
conditions so my belief is
joe rogan is not going to be affected by
this in any way
next email today is from daniel
daniel says evidence the pentagon
has gave way more money
to the wuhan lab
than dr fauci's nih
and the fact that peter dazzak
is the main one who gave all that money
to the wuhan scientists directly and how
one seems to care
i think what daniel is trying to say
is that despite what he believes to be
evidence about money going from the nih
to the wuhan lab
that no one seems to care i i believe
that that's what this email is about
um
listen i've weighed in on this before
my view is uh i want to know
the truth about the world period
i am not this is not a show where
either for posturing
or for narrative crafting or for any
reason
i
exclude things from the show that i
believe are important
or lie to the audience in any way i
always give my opinion i want to know
the truth about the wuhan lab and
funding and dr fauci and the entire
thing
i think what's important is that we
understand first of all how much of this
entire dr fouchy controversy
fundamentally comes down to semantics
which i talked about last week on the
friday show with a caller who called in
that's number one
um and number two um there is a lot of
misinformation about this issue so i
continue
to
look when things come across my desk or
my screen as it might better be said um
into the nih wuhan issue
and if i have some kind of major thing
to come to you with and say sirs and
mams
here's some news
uh you can rest assured that i will do
that let's go to the next email
this is very weaponized now i should
actually even take it off the screen for
a second
if there are kids in the room get them
out if you have dogs that are
particularly sensitive to cringe get
them out cats they don't give a damn
what the hell is on the screen uh but in
all seriousness this this is very very
weaponized william wrote to me and said
they all died
david
i am the only member of my family and
friend group
who was smart enough to not listen to
celebrity propaganda
and unfortunately i was right
almost everyone i know personally has
died from a vaccine
my mother and i are the only ones left
she took the vaccine but thankfully her
immune system kicked it out that's
actually it's so it's so crazy it's
funny
what am i supposed to do now that
everybody i know and love is dead
because of your stupid vaccine
um
does this even deserve a reply
like i don't even i'm not even you know
um
this is either
someone i mean like what what is this
right okay so it could be just someone
who's trolling fine let's imagine it's
not
this could be someone whose family
really has tragically died
from different issues could be even
covered
and they are wrongly blaming it on being
vaccinated also they say from a vaccine
not necessarily even covet so it could
be someone who is misattributing death
to vaccines
could be someone who's completely
delusional and disconnected from the
real world
um i don't know could could be a serial
murderer who's killed people and is
saying it was vaccine this could be
anything
other than what it purports to be i
think that that's sort of where i would
leave it uh but these folks are out
there
anthony wrote to me and said
misleading characterization mr pacman it
is often stated in the media that most
republicans believe trump won the 2020
election wouldn't it be more accurate to
say that most republicans
claim they believe trump won the
election big difference no this is a
beautiful question
we talked about this before
um and we talked about this in a segment
where i talked about the kind of magical
thinking and we're at war mentality of
many of these trump supporters where we
wondered
when they say
we believe trump won
do they really believe it or is it the
way they are choosing to answer polls in
order to be part of the right team and
in order to perpetuate some more general
idea that they don't like joe biden they
don't like that joe biden won
and i think that
i i know i've been citing this a lot
lately
but
neil postman in technopoly has a very
good couple pages about exactly this
issue about opinion polling which is
opinion polling
we
opinion polling becomes an invisible
technology in the sense that we just
look at the results of the poll and we
don't think about why was it done who
did it what does it really mean to
answer questions in one way or the other
and how were the questions asked
and
what a poll tells us is
an opinion poll tells us what people
claim to believe
and people might claim to believe
something they don't believe for
different reasons we talked you know
there was this idea that the the polls
leading into 2020 that said joe biden
was winning were wrong
because the wrong people were being
pulled right sampling problem
or there were people
bashful trump supporters not willing to
say that they supported trump but they
really did it it ended up basically
being false i mean wisconsin was off
there's no doubt about it but it
basically was was not true
but when it comes to what people believe
about the 2020 election it's important
to say that the polls tell us what
people claim to believe and they may not
actually believe the things they claim
to believe for a whole bunch of
different reasons very good point a next
email is from larry larry says keep
drinking now it gets crazy
now by the way keep drinking the
kool-aid biden is the worst president in
my lifetime a liar a wife stealer and he
has been selling out our country for his
family's benefit for decades
it sounds like larry's describing trump
quite frankly larry goes on to say
trader joe's where everything is for
sale
big far here we go with this stuff big
pharma must also love you they are also
a criminal organization and have you
convinced hook line and sinker that they
are our savior open your eyes young man
so
the first part is just whacked i mean
like hard whacked
um
the the last part you know a bunch of
people have written in and they've said
david clearly you're being paid to
promote vaccines and i tweeted about
this earlier in the week
why would anyone pay me to promote like
first of all promote
i report on the science of vaccines
um but
why would anyone pay me
to promote vaccines we're we're small
potatoes right like in in the grand
scheme of things it would be sort of a
dumb thing to do and in addition why
would they pay me given that i've
reported on the science of vaccines for
a long time like they don't
what else can i really say about
vaccines other than reporting when they
work and uh what the impact of those
vaccinations is and this is part of the
sort of superstructure around
vaccination disinformation that's out
there which is that some of the people
there's lies being told it's all lies is
the point um there's lies being told
about how safe the vaccine is that's the
people who email in and they say
thousands
tens of thousands hundreds of thousands
of people died from the vaccine that's
one part but then also the people
telling you what they claim is the
science of vaccines
those people have been paid
so they simply can't be believed it
looks like they're giving you science
but they're giving you stuff they've
been given by someone that paid them
and the whole point of it is not to just
accept reality and live in in this other
world which is preferable to them
it's a preferable world to them it's
simpler and that's the appeal of some
conspiracy theories a lot of people find
it
hard to accept
that
bad things happen unpredictable things
happen every 100 years or so we get a
100-year pandemic
but we've got a vaccine that helps
that sounds out of control to a lot of
people it's more appealing to believe
this was all just done by humans um
that's where you get the vaccine i'm
sorry the virus was created in a bio
weapons lab and released because that's
control it's not a random event
it's not a probabilistic event anymore
and the vaccine is also part of the
exact same plot it's all a plot for some
people
even though they claim to be outraged by
it they would rather live in a world
where everything is controlled by man
rather than than things that can happen
that are left to chance unpredictable
bad things that's at the root of much
conspiracism okay last one today here's
a bonus
um this one came in via facebook on
monday morning this is from george this
is really wild george says
you keep calling trump supporters
delusional
i truly hope that you open your eyes
before the communist
democrat
nazi party come for you
a few contradictions there
trump did not lose the 2020 election
it was part of a colors revolution
colors
revolution educate yourself
educate your followers and open your
eyes otherwise you might just find yours
you might find yourself on that train
just like the jews found themselves on a
nazi train
except this time it won't be gas
it'll be an injection
they call it a vaccine dumbass
folks
folks
this is what we're up against we're
gonna have to try to solve the problems
of humanity
despite people like this i don't see any
way to get them to help us maybe we can
prevent them from hurting us maybe
but it is not looking very good not
looking very good get your emails in for
next week's mailbag info
davidpakman.com we have a fantastic
bonus show today it's all me today on
the bonus show i know many people
expecting only producer pat today it's
all me i will see you on the bonus show